HERE.IT'S FRIDAY AND THAT MEANS
IT'S TIME FOR FRIDAY VOLLEY.
AND FOR THAT WE TURN TO OUR FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR.
HE HAD A BIT OF IT TOUGH WEEK O
PUBLIC EVENTS.
SEEMS TO MY EYES THAT HE SEEMS
TO BE REVERTING BACK TO HIS OLD
WAYS.
I DON'T THINK YOUR EYES DECEIVE
YOU.
ON MONDAY THE PRESENT SET THIS
LINE HAS GOT HIM IN TROUBLE IN
THE PAST.
>> MY DAD WAS A SALESPERSON.
HE WASN'T A COAL MINER.
>> HIS GREAT GRANDFATHER WAS NO
A COAL MINER EITHER HE WAS AN
ENGINEER.
HE DIDN'T EXTRACT COAL FROM
ANYTHING.
>> IT'S A LIE HE FESSED UP TO
BACK IN 2004.
>> HOW DO YOU LIKE THAT HE'S
TRIED THAT BEFORE.
HE JUST KEEPS TRYING IT AND IT'
NOT WORKING OUT VERY WELL.
REMEMBER THIS IS A SKILL THAT H
REFERENCED RIGHT HERE.
'S 1998 PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN H
STOLE THE SPEECH FROM A
SECRETARY IN ABOUT UNITED
KINGDOM REFERENCING RELATIVES
WORKING IN THE COAL MINE.
IN THE WASHINGTON POST THEY SAI
HE WENT TOO FAR BUT WE AREN'T
GIVING HIM ANYTHING.
FIRST OF ALL THAT WAS 17 YEARS
AGO?
HE WAS NO SPRING CHICKEN BACK
THEN.
THIS SEEMS LIKE AGING IS TOUGH.
BUT IT'S LIKE HE'S A DIFFERENT
PERSON.
>> WHETHER IT'S HIS AGE OR
MENTAL STATE WE ARE REACHING A
POINT WHERE PLAGIARIZING
PERSONAL NARRATIVES IS
CONFLICTING WITH REALITY.
THE NAMES AND THE FACTS THEY AR
ALL ELUSIVE.
>> YOU PREDICT THIS IN PRACTICE
AND DISCIPLINE ON LAND AND IN
THE SEA.
WE HAVE TO BE SURE WOMEN HAVE A
CHANCE TO SUCCEED.
WOMEN HOLD UP HALF THE WORLD.
IT'S A STUPID POSITION TO NOT
HAVE WE DO.
>> FIRST OF ALL HIS QUOTING A
CHINESE DICTATOR.
THE LINE IS WOMEN HOLD UP HALF
THE SKY NOT THE WORLD.
HE INTENDS TO PUSH WOMEN INTO
THE FACTORIES.
>>LAURA: YOU ARE SPEAKING TO TH
US COAST GUARD AND YOU ARE
QUOTING A NOTORIOUS DICTATOR IN
A POSITIVE WAY.
IT'S HOW TO ACHIEVE A MILITARY
ADVERSARY.
YOU COULD OPEN UP A QUOTE ANY
DAY OF THE WEEK BUT WHY GO WITH
THIS